This next story is just hilarious, but it's
also infuriating in a way.
And I'll tell you why.
Donald Trump's former defense secretary, Jim
Mattis, who was always one of the people with
a head on his shoulders, other than being
a total tool of militarism, a gym, that this
was more or less sensible, more or less connected
to reality when it came to Trump being a clueless
person that is reportedly said, we're now
learning back when Trump wanted to do that
ridiculous 4th of July military parade with
the tanks that would destroy the roads in
the entire thing.
Jim Maddis reportedly said, I'd rather swallow
acid.
That's a quote I'd rather swallow acid than
watch Trump's military parade.
Now I like this because it confirms that Matt
is not only had a sense of how ridiculous
Trump's actions were, he also had sort of
a clever sense of humor.
The book we're talking about is called holding
the line inside Trump's Pentagon with secretary
Mattis, which was written by retired Navy
commander guys.
Snodgrass Snodgrass was Madison's communications
director and had speech writer and the book
has a ton of interesting stuff in it, not
the least of which is Madison's preference
for swallowing acid over watching Donald Trump's
military parade.
The book also says that Trump wanted to screw
up, quote, screw Amazon CEO and turbo billionaire
Jeff Bezos by keeping Amazon out of the bidding
process for a Pentagon contract for some kind
of big a networked computing, networking it
installation.
So the trend of most of what's in the book
is in line with everything we've seen Donald
Trump do, which is there's always a personal
angle to it.
Trump is president and he's supposed to be
doing what's best for the United States, but
Pentagon networking contract.
I want to screw Jeff Bezos military aid to
Ukraine.
I want Ukraine to smear Biden for the benefit
of my 2020 reelection campaign.
And the real embarrassment is that for anything
we can say about Maddis now he understands
Trump is bonkers.
He wanted to swallow acid instead of watching
the parade or whatever.
Where was Maddis earlier?
Right?
Well, why didn't Matt stand up to Trump sooner?
And we know the answer.
And unfortunately, you know, Trump did untold
damage through decisions that Maddis could
have at least tried to stand up to Trump about.
He would have been fired or forced to resign
obviously, but he could have done it.
Maddis has buyer's remorse from working for
Donald Trump, but where was that assessment
at the start? Trump.
It's, we didn't have to wait and see who Donald
Trump was going to be as president.
Trump as president is exactly who we knew
him to be the day he hired Jim Mattis and
Mattis went along with it for a long time
and it's important to accept the accurate
statements of these former Trump officials
to the extent that they're accurate now in
hindsight, but we can't allow them to rehabilitate
their images so easily.
We discussed this yesterday on the bonus show.
Actually, we talked about it with regard to
Sean Spicer, a former just embarrassingly
bad at or dishonest press secretary who now
is rehabbing his image on, I didn't even know
this.
Pat told me on dancing with the stars.
Sarah Huckabee Sanders, who is a, I don't
really know what she's doing, but she could
potentially at some point be governor of Arkansas
who knows a long list of people who as soon
as they leave the administration and they
sort of seem to be connected with reality,
we often immediately improve our opinion of
them.
It's great that they're recognizing it now,
but the truth is they probably recognize it
then they said nothing.
They saw only their personal career potential
that, uh, was associated with participating
in this completely a board of presidency.
And we should not allow them to rehabilitate
their image in the way that they are.
So, so obviously trying to do at this point
in time, uh, there's other, remind me who
else there is.
I mean, I obviously, I know, um, Spicer and
Huckabee are two of the big players.
Uh, Rex Tillerson, although he doesn't really
need to rehab his image, he's, uh, you know,
ready to retire at least financially, if not
ideologically.
Um, but there are others and we've gotta be
really careful about allowing them to now
just be seen as normal people because there's
nothing normal about going along with it for
the weeks, months or years that they did before.
They said, I can't do this anymore.
Or Trump kicked him out.